what's up reject nation I'm Will Smith
I'm also Will Smith ha Gemini yeah yeah
that's hilarious
alright let's watch Will Smith be Will
Smith double the Smith every trick I've
ever pulled
howdy start you hunting birds rabbit
guessing 19 20 years old the first time
he ordered you to shoot a person
[Music]
25 years ago he took my blood
you
they're lying to you the whole time I
told you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world why would he send
you
Wow you are obviously not the best man
[Music]
he has to die he's your darkness you had
to walk through this on your own
[Music]
oh goodness gracious me well Smith is
just killing it this years I mean I
think this movie looks like a lot of fun
it does I think it looks cool I feel
like Will Smith is probably gonna
elevate this [ __ ] out of this material
I've heard that yeah yeah hey he looks
great in it he does look great I'm
having a hard time taking this plot
seriously that's like the action looks
cool the effects of the devil wills
looks really good and I feel like Will
Smith is gonna be awesome in it and I
feel like they're probably some cool
action one thing this reminded me of is
that my introduction angley was
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
where he showed he can really capture
action really well despite where do you
even think about the whole day if you
didn't like the movie or not I think he
does a great job capturing the action
there ever since then he knows like
Brokeback Man and Life of Pi that nc-17
movie less caution we don't really
associate him as action director he can
really do action very well so this looks
great for some reason this just feels
like such a 90s movie I don't know if
that's intentional or not though like
these action heroes wears like a
jean-claude Van Damme film yeah yeah
yeah and it feels like I've seen most of
the plot and most of the themes brought
up in in both of these trailers goodness
so I don't really feel like I mean hey
the movie might have surprises and I
hope it does but right now yeah it feels
like a lot of really cool innovation for
a kind of familiar plot or a plot that
it's been expounded upon over the years
and I feel bad for them because they've
been trying to get this movie made since
1997 and so many people have been
attached to it over time yeah that I
wonder if maybe the plot has been
kind of boiled down over the years you
know well one thing I was looking
forward to when I was watching like the
behind the scenes of this recently by
recently I mean 5:50 a.m. I hit 11:00 so
I was watching it that moment in the
keeps running the trailer where young
will is crying yeah and then in the
behind the scenes you see that he has
like all those a crap on his head yeah
as mocap stuff Wow to get so into
character with all that [ __ ] on your
head yeah it's really impressive - yeah
it's like good to get pulled into the
reality of it that's why I'm thinking
the visual effects will be awesome
action will be cool will be fine Clive
Owen looks so cheesy though yeah Clive
Owens the only one who seems to be
representing the tone that the trailer
is trying to hide well that's the thing
too is I heard that this trailer is
gonna be a much better balance of the
drama of the movie and the action of the
movie but this felt very similar to the
first trailer to me honestly I mean we
got maybe a bit more action we certainly
got scenes do this another hat wrap it
diverse trailers like did Robbie time
but then let's show how cool is gonna be
in this one right yeah I don't really
feel like we got any new story beats and
yeah the most special thing about this
whole movie to me seems to be the visual
dressing it's going for because this is
shot like a hundred twenty frames a
second which is insane that's almost
three times what they did The Hobbit in
it and so I got imagine that's gonna
make the effects perhaps that much more
convincing because they keep going on
about how this is engaging it's a
completely digital Will Smith for the
younger version and so with all those
extra frames that's got to make that
animation look good I've heard the
scenes in which they're fighting each
other directly are spectacular to behold
yeah the problem is which is a bummer
because it's got so many good things
working for it basically he's here some
ass yeah she had a couple of cool him
moments yeah is she gonna be a character
is she gonna be it's gonna come in
halfway through it be like I know what's
going on with you and I'm here to
yeah or something well evoke live oh and
just look so Gordy but he loves him he
loves jr. oh he does he does no he does
he loves that vial of blood that became
jr. this movie has to do a good job at
convincing me that if he is the like
young well clearly is the one with the
ego he's the one who believes I mean
they both have egos but he's the one who
believes he is like the absolute match
even though he's been caught in that
moment he's like I'm still pissed a lot
working against me age fat for him to
fall for what is like watching five
seconds of Clio and I'm like to not pick
if he's not picking up on that then
that's gonna be just kind of an annoying
stroke to me I don't know what tone this
movie's gonna be and I feel like tones
gonna make the biggest difference in
experiencing this movie now because one
trailer was like the heaviest emotional
it was like watching after earth but
like the posters are like after herbs
but without he's like now just throw me
back in there yeah and then this one was
we're heavy now we have cool rap music
and I just don't know what this movie's
going for I have no idea what they're
trying to pull off here you know
probably a late-night fight twist just
go back to that era and find out you
know what funny enough you know who
almost starred in this back of the day
is your boy we almost had Tom Ehlers oh
wow he almost had to Mel's ooh yeah oh
no yeah
young man I would have wanted AFC male
out
punchin each other no no can you imagine
Clive Owen being like I love you and
well are you guys excited for Gemini man
we're gonna watch we also despite
whatever concerns always have its you
know I'm just gonna watch it this
Halloween subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification Belgian notify
whenever we have a video up you can go
ahead follow us on the Stardust app
actually over there with you 30-second
reaction
use for any film TV show and/or trailer
we post throughout the week we pose are
pretty consistent lately you can post
your own content up there - the whole
thing is completely free to download and
use and before I wrap this up oh let's
save a page from the day shout-out to a
woman named Rosa Parra Rosa reviews go
check her out on Instagram and Twitter I
love reading all of her posts she has
some of the best reviews that I think
you guys would absolutely enjoy so
efficiently told so honest so raw and I
usually agree with what she has to say
she's been the lady start of our Channel
and she has been quite the light and
made a major impact in our lives
personally Rosa I've been going through
some hard stuff lately but you keep on
trekking on and I think that's part of
what makes you so special to us is that
no matter the hardships you still remain
to be a strong beautiful hard-working
mother who never gives up which is why
we're gonna clone you and we're gonna
clone you make multiple roses because
soon there will be a whole army and I'm
gonna have the young Rosa for some odd
reason try to kill older rose yeah I
don't know why you know I'm not gonna
consult you about this clothing process
aging and youthful inherit the earth
Oh
smooth